Israel has been carrying out more
airstrikes against militants in the Gaza
Strip after its targeted killing of a
top Palestinian commander overnight
Israel says Baha Abu alotta of the
Palestinian militant group Islamic Jihad
was behind a series of rocket attacks on
its territory Palestinian militants
responded by firing rockets at Israeli
cities including Tel Aviv citizens
across southern and central Israel have
been instructed instructed to stay
inside it is one of the worst
escalations of violence on the Israel
Gaza border in years and for more on
this story we can speak to journalists
hassan volusia he's following this in
gaza city high Hussam thank you for
joining us can you bring us up to date
on what's been happening at the moment
there in Gaza well as you mentioned
today was a day of exchanging fire
firing rockets from Gaza tens of rockets
were fired from Gaza in today's wavy
cities reach tel-aviv but most of it was
sudeerneer by cities that Israeli Jets
and and air forces targeted many places
mainly military sites and some of the
those some people some they no faction
claimed responsibility or announced
anything but apparently they are those
people who was according to Israel they
stand behind firing rockets so since the
morning Gaza is is a different day it's
out of sudden there is escalation after
years of of the quietness schools
government institutions and banks are
closed today in Gaza no Israeli Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu he did speak
earlier at a press conference let's
listen now to what he said about the
killing of this Gaza militant but on our
corner of a missile Umezu in the past
year this arch terrorist was the main
generator of terrorism from the strip he
initiated planned and carried out many
attacks he fired hundreds of rockets at
communities in the Gaza / if
who's suffering we haven't ignored he
was in the midst of crossing additional
attacks these very days he was a ticking
bomb so we heard the words they're a
ticking bomb
you know how significant was he well I
mean actually uh it's it's weird how
this name become in the top news
actually the name of bob latta appeared
like a couple of month ago as israel
accused him of standing behind foreign
rockets into israel precisely at the
when the rockets fired when when
Netanyahu himself was giving a speech in
a city of eyes dude before the elections
he is not the top leader of military
wing of Islamic Jihad he is not the
first person he is one of the commanders
who's in as Islamic Jihad said he is the
documental of Northland region or in the
Gaza Strip the talks and and and and and
people started to talk about about him
since the Israelis started to accuse him
of standing behind the Rockets four out
into Israel and it has now led to this
as you said significant escalation as
and what do you think this is heading
well this is the this is a hard question
to answer it's it's too early to say
that if there is going to be an a fourth
war
it depends actually to be honest on on
the Hamas reaction Hamas is the biggest
power in in Gaza and it has it's the
biggest military capabilities in Gaza if
they joined directly the the retaliation
and they responded and fire and rockets
into Israel it might go broader and
bigger but if Hamas which is more
willingly according to the analyst that
will will will give the opportunity to
Islamic Jihad to respond and firing
rockets which means that this would be
limited and it will has an end within
short time maybe days maybe hours we
don't know all right journalists house
in Volusia speaking to us from Gaza City
thank you very much